THE SUPREME COURT,
THE KNOWLEDGEABLE NINE, EL
GRANDE JUSTIVO.
ROBES, ROBES, ROBES.
YESTERDAY, AMERICA DROPPED DOWN
ON ONE KNEE AND PROPOSED ORAL
ARGUMENTS THAT COULD SETTLE THE
QUESTION OF MARRIAGE EQUALITY
FOR GAY PEOPLE.
>> THE COURT WILL ANSWER TWO
QUESTIONS-- CAN STATES REFUSE TO
ISSUE MARRIAGE LICENSES TO
SAME-SEX COUPLES, AND CAN THEY
DECLINE TO RECOGNIZE SAME-SEX
MARRIAGES THAT WERE LEGALLY
GRANTED SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> Jon: AND CAN THE COURT ANSWER
THOSE WHILE TRAVELING THE WORLD.
THAT'S RIGHT, THE
SUPREME COURT IS HEARING THOSE
CASES WHILE PARTICIPATING IN
THIS YEAR'S "AMAZING RACE."
( LAUGHTER )
SHE SEEMS-- SHE SEEMS PERFECTLY
COMFORTABLE ON A ZIP LINE.
( LAUGHTER )
OF COURSE, AN ISSUE THIS
IMPORTANT WAS BOUND TO DRAW A
CROWD, MAKING THEIR FINAL
ARGUMENTS.
THE PROGAY MARRIAGE CAMP WENT
WITH HOW CAN A JUST GOD NOT
ALLOW TWO MEN THIS INTO BEARD
CARE NOT BE TOGETHER?
WHILE THE ANTIGAY MARRIAGE CROWD
WENT WITH WHY DON'T WE SUMMON
THE ANCIENT HEBREWS AND SEE WHAT
THEY SAY?
BY THE WAY, YES, THAT IS A
SHOFAR, AND YES, THE ANTIGAY MAN
IS BLOWING IT.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
BUT, IT WOULDN'T -- IRONY. ALL
RIGHT.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
BUT IT WOULDN'T BE UP TO THOSE
OUTSIDE THE COURT.
>> THIS WILL, IN ALL LIKELIHOOD
COME DOWN TO JUSTICE KENNEDY.
>> Jon: KENNEDY, KENNEDY,
KENNEDY!
THE ONLY JUSTICE ANYONE
EVER CARES ABOUT IS KENNEDY.
HE'S THE MARCIA TO THE
SUPREME COURT'S EIGHT JANS.
BUT TUESDAY'S SESSION WAS MAINLY
A FORUM FOR
GAY MARRIAGE
OPPONENTS TO AIR THEIR BEST AND
FINAL ARGUMENTS WHICH WE LOOK AT
IN TONIGHT'S SEGMENT, YOU GOT
NOTHING, SO-CALLED BECAUSE
OPPONENTS OF GAY MARRIAGE GOT
NOTHING.
AND THEY TRIED EVERYTHING,
STARTING WITH THE GOOD, OLD,
CLASSIC SLIPPERY SLOPE.
>> SUPPOSE WE RULE IN YOUR FAVOR
IN THIS CASE, AND AFTER THAT, A
GROUP CONSISTING OF TWO MEN AND
TWO WOMEN APPLY FOR A MARRIAGE
LICENSE.
WOULD THERE BE ANY GROUND FOR
DENYING THEM A LICENSE?
>> Jon: WHY SHOULD GAY
PEOPLE HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR
ANYONE WHO IS EVER GOING TO WANT
TO GET MARRIED AFTER THEY GET
THE RIGHT TO MARRY?
WHEN WOMEN FOUGHT FOR SUFFRAGE
NO WAS ONE LIKE WHAT IF ONE DAY
A DOG WANTS TO VOTE.
HOW ABOUT THAT, LADIES?
BECAUSE NEXT THING YOU KNOW THE
STATE OF OUR UNION IS...
( BARK )
BY THE WAY, I LIKE THAT THE
SPEAKER IS A CAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THAT IS.
SO THAT WAS ONE DUMB ARGUMENT
BUT HARDLY THE ONLY ONE.
>> IF YOU PREVAIL HERE, THERE
WILL BE NO MORE DEBATE.
I MEAN, CLOSING THE DEBATE CAN
CLOSE MINDS, AND IT WILL HAVE A
CONSEQUENCE ON HOW THIS NEW
INSTITUTION IS ACCEPTED.
PEOPLE FEEL VERY DIFFERENTLY
ABOUT SOMETHING IF THEY HAVE A
CHANCE TO VOTE ON IT THAN IF
IT'S IMPOSED ON THEM BY-- BY THE
COURTS.
>> Jon: SURE, NO, THAT MAKES
SENSE.
IF YOU DON'T IMPOSE GAY
MARRIAGE
FOLKS LIKE THIS WILL BE MORE
OPEN MINDED.
( LAUGHTER )
TO EVOLVING THEIR POSITION.
YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
SEE.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
YEAH.
BUT THE POINT WAS CLEAR.
THIS CASE THREATENS NOT JUST
MARRIAGE BUT OUR VERY DEMOCRACY.
>> WHEN YOU ENACT SOCIAL CHANGE
OF THIS MAGNITUDE THROUGH THE
FEDERAL COURTS THAT'S NOT THE
WAY THAT OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
IS SUPPOSED TO WORK, AND THERE
ARE LONG-TERM HARMS TO OUR
COUNTRY AND TO THAT FUNDAMENTAL
LIBERTY INTEREST TO GOVERN
OURSELVES.
>> Jon: FIRST OF ALL, LET
ME JUST SAY I LOVE YOUR LAWYER
COSTUME.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
SECONDLY, IT'S BALLS FOR A YOUNG
GUY TO WALK INTO THE SUPREME
COURT AND SAY I KNOW YOU THINK
MARBURY VERSUS MADISON GIVES
YOU THE RIGHT TO DECIDE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS BUT I
SAY WE'RE A DIRECT DEMOCRACY.
NOW, WHICH ONE OF YOU PRICKS IS
GOING TO BUY ME BOOZE, I'M 19?
( LAUGHTER )
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
WE HAVE BOTH A FUNDAMENTAL
LIBERTY TO GOVERN AND A COURT
EMPOWERED TO STOP US FROM
ABUSING THAT LIBERTY TO TAKE
OTHER PEOPLE'S LIBERTY.
THAT'S HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
AND IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THE
COURT'S DECISION, WELL THEN YOU
JUST HAVE TO SUCK IT UP,
SOMETIMES FOR YEARS, WITH
HORRIBLE CONSEQUENCES.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
SO ENOUGH WITH THE DEMOCRACY!
ENOUGH!
CAN A BROTHER GET A LAME APPEAL
TO HISTORY ARGUMENT UP IN HERE?
>> EVERY DEFINITION THAT I
LOOKED UP PRIOR TO ABOUT A DOZEN
YEARS AGO DEFINED MARRIAGE
AS THE UNITY BETWEEN A MAN
AND A WOMAN AS HUSBAND AND WIFE.
OBVIOUSLY, IF YOU SUCCEED, THAT
CORE DEFINITION WILL NO LONGER
BE OPERABLE.
YOU'RE NOT SEEKING TO JOIN
THE INSTITUTION.
YOU'RE SEEKING TO CHANGE WHAT
THE INSTITUTION IS.
>> Jon: THE INSTITUTION OF
MARRIAGE HAS ALMOST NEVER NOT
BEEN CHANGING.
BEFORE THE LAST CENTURY,
MARRIAGE WASN'T ONE MAN AND ONE
WOMAN.
IT WAS ONE MAN AND HIS NEW PIECE
OF VAGINA PROPERTY.
( LAUGHTER )
CHANGE CAN BE GOOD.
BUT THE ANTIGAY CRAY-CRAY--
( APPLAUSE )
PROBABLY PEAKED WITH THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE POINT OF
MARRIAGE ITSELF.
>> IF YOU'RE CHANGING THE
MEANING OF MARRIAGE FROM ONE
WHERE IT'S BASED ON THE
BIOLOGICAL BOND TO ONE
WHERE IT'S BASED ON EMOTIONAL
COMMITMENT, THEN ADULTS
COULD THINK, RIGHTLY, THAT THIS
RELATIONSHIP IS MORE ABOUT
ADULTS AND NOT ABOUT THE KIDS.
>> Jon: WHOA!
( LAUGHTER )
GAY MARRIAGE ISN'T ABOUT KIDS?
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO PARK
SLOPE?
OH, LOOK!
THE ELIZABETHS HAVE THE NEW
DYSON UPPA BABY XL HOVER
CARRIAGE.
THAT WON'T BE HARD TO CLIMB OVER
TO GET INTO BEANS AND SUCH.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT, ALL RIGHT, LET'S PLAY THIS
OUT.
>> SUPPOSE THAT THERE'S A STATE
WITH A VERY
PRO-CREATION-CENTERED VIEW OF
MARRIAGE OF THE KIND THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SO WHEN PEOPLE COME IN AND ASK
FOR A MARRIAGE LICENSE, THEY
JUST ASK A SIMPLE QUESTION, "DO
YOU WANT CHILDREN?"
AND IF THE ANSWER IS NO, THE
STATE SAYS, "NO MARRIAGE LICENSE
FOR YOU."
WOULD THAT BE CONSTITUTIONAL?
>> Jon: OH SNAP, THAT WAS VERY
RABBINICAL.
SOMEWHAT OBTUSE.
ANYONE WANT TO TAKE A MORE
PRACTICAL SWING AT THIS?
>> SUPPOSE A 70-YEAR-OLD COUPLE
COMES IN AND THEY WANT--
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: AND THIS
70-YEAR-OLD COUPLE, NO MATTER
HOW MUCH THEY'RE ( BLEEP ), AND
THEY'RE ( BLEEP ) A LOT -- IN
THE SIT-DOWN SHOWER, ON THAT--
ON THAT ELECTRIC STAIR CHAIR,
BENT OVER THE MAHJONG TABLE--
THEY'RE NOT HAVING KIDS.
IS THEIRS NOT A CONSTITUTIONALLY
WORTHY ( BLEEP )-FEST FILLED
LOVE AS WELL?
( LAUGHTER )
BUT FAIR QUESTION.
WHAT IF-- WHAT IF A COUPLE OF
70-YEAR-OLDS WANT TO GET
MARRIED, COUNSELOR?
IF MARRIAGE IS FOR HAVING
KIDS WHY SHOULD THAT BE ALLOWED?
AND WHEN ANSWERING TRY TO STEP
AS HARD AND DEEP INTO A PILE OF
DOG ( BLEEP ) AS POSSIBLE.
>> WELL, A 70-YEAR-OLD MAN,
OBVIOUSLY, IS STILL CAPABLE OF
HAVING CHILDREN AND YOU LIKE TO
KEEP THAT WITHIN THE MARRIAGE.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, I THINK
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER OFF
ANSWERING HAM ANA-HAM ANA-HAM
ANA.
SPINNING THE BOW TIE, THROWING A
SMOKE BOMB AND GETTING THE
( BLEEP ) OUT OF ROOM.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS-- IF
ORAL ARGUMENTS HAVE ANY IMPACT
ON THE FINAL RESULTS, JUNE IS
GOING TO BE A NICE TIME FOR A
GAY WEDDING.